so Margaret Marcelli is a mother who
lives outside Toronto Canada she's got a
23 year old son who suffers from
depression and diabetes also he doesn't
have a girlfriend
on that basis alone doctors have just
approved
her son's assisted suicide a doctor
called Joshua Tepper signed off on it to
kill the boy because he sat and doesn't
have a girlfriend we know this because
of the substant common sense you can
read the details and you should they're
shocking this is about to become a lot
more common in Canada as a way of
cutting down on health care costs
by March new law and Canada is expected
to allow children to be killed by
doctors by state Doctors Without the
approval of their parents it seems like
a very big change in western
civilization Charles camassi is a
professor at Creighton School of
Medicine he's the author of losing our
dignity who joins us tonight
um I sure appreciate your coming on to
assess this we've had this conversation
multiple times and each time we do we
reach a new and more terrifying load
doctors killing kids without telling
their parents because the kids are
depressed
let's see if I have the laundry list
Riot Tucker at this point we've got kids
now are what they call mature miners
we've got the homeless we talked about
that last time the poor the disabled
those with chronic pain and then right
before coming on I researched the
Physicians Group in Quebec that wants to
kill newborn infants that's what's
coming next the Toronto Star Tucker a
very liberal paper in Canada called this
Hunger Games Social Darwinism
this is what happens Tucker when a
autonomy just goes nuts
I mean you hate to I I really try never
to invoke the Nazis because
you know for many reasons but they are
famous for doing this exact thing use
doctors to murder the weakest in your
society and I thought that doctors kind
of agreed after the second world war not
to do things like this
yeah you would think and I'm the same
way I think we should be very very
hesitant to use those arguments but at a
certain point Tucker
um if the shoe fits we Canada has to
wear it now the question is can we stop
this from coming to the United States it
hasn't got here yet and I think we can
for instance New York Connecticut even
deep blue States like that have not uh
legalized even assisted suicide yet and
so what we need to do Tucker and all
your listeners need to do this is
support in whatever way you can
Healthcare that is about caring
uh not killing in fact there is a
coalition of people there's a coalition
of people coming up with a brand new
medical school the Padre Pio School of
Medicine in 2026 that is going to do
this very clearly very ably and if
others would like to join a coalition of
people who are doing this I urge them to
send me a message through my website
charleskamosi.com or through Twitter
because we have to get off the couch and
do something about this for those of us
that see the writing on the wall here
shouldn't the American Medical
Association weigh in and just say
unequivocally doctors the United States
don't get to kill children just because
children are depressed a doctor's job is
to help people make them better not to
kill them give up on them when they're
kids
well as I wrote at length of losing our
dignity Tucker we have a very very
different Health Care system than we had
even 20 or 30 years ago it is hyper um
secularized it is often based on
cost-benefit analyzes even something
called quality adjusted life years which
is basically ableism we've had a lot of
talk about ableism over the last couple
days this is ableism right here and it's
no accident that the disability rights
groups are our biggest allies in this we
should continue to employ them as again
we get up off the couch here and fight
yeah amen get off the couch and fight
that's exactly right professor Charles
campus thank you as always
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight